try to make your Tim in so this
hand always the center it starts to move
softens I'm
aiming that
way think it more like a a stone rolling
down the hill so the hips start
it the arm and the body
that way your dead weight your
mass will take you where you need to go
if you if he holds really strong and and
he's grounded and you you you tried to
step out here and keep that
shoulder there you get
that doing it this way as
well sort of like makes it so that he
slowly comes over not too far he's still
on come here come down here keep it on
there the idea is to keep it on the
shoulder not to take it off the shoulder
and then that bottom
foot so how you be key on first and then
if you don't do slowly first so you know
it's a bit like meeting the tiger
meeting the mountain if you you don't
that
first you all of a sudden find it he's
being awkward it's because you're you
rashed at it too quick you you not you
not
found
the not been able to so go into the
power